for the season and the timberwolves  can't quite run out the clock  there's about a one second difference  but  the timberwolves are salting this thing  away and how good does this feel  for everybody on the timberwolves floor  right now  players coaches  first game they played in 288  days and the timberwolves  are going to get a win to start off  their 2020 2021 season and they got  contributions from virtually  everybody the bench had a huge hand in  this as well  of course russell came off the bench  tonight so technically  normally a starter but they gave rubio  the start tonight  i'm just very happy for carl anthony  thomas in a game that is so emotional  for him  we had you know tributes before the game  to jackie townes to sid hartman  and to the great tom hanneman very  emotional night for karl-anthony towns